[Musik]
breaking news
willkommen zurück beide live an diesem
tag an dem russland und den gashahn
zugedreht hat die pipeline nord stream 1
die es seit heute morgen um 6 dicht ganz
regulär angeblich nur für elf tage und
es sind die alljährlichen
wartungsarbeiten des russischen
gasunternehmen gazprom bis zum 21 juli
soll das ganze dauern aber wird das gas
danach wieder fließen die angst vor
einer sogenannten politischen wartung
also der künstlich verlängerten
zwangspause die bleibt und das gerade
jetzt wo die gas versorgungslage in
deutschland mehr als angespannt ist
schon seit wochen liefert russland
deutlich weniger
unsere kollegin eine garage ist für uns
vor ort am bundeskanzleramt annika was
ist deine einschätzung was hast du von
den politikern wird das nach elf tagen
wieder geregelt werden und wir werden
wieder gas bekommen aus russland
theresa grad schon richtig gesagt die
angst ist groß hinter mir im kanzleramt
werden heute abend auf jeden fall noch
die lichter leuchten denn das kanzleramt
das
2001 bezogen wurde das neue dass der
neubau
gewinnt sein strom durch biodiesel
sonnenenergie und ökostrom trotzdem hat
das kanzleramt auch ein notstromaggregat
und das ist eben auch das was man jetzt
unternehmen und sogar privaten
haushalten empfiehlt das heißt die sorge
ist natürlich groß und das zeigt eben
wie ernst die lage wirklich ist jetzt
kann man sich auf das wort von putin
nicht unbedingt verlassen dass in elf
tagen das ganze wieder läuft dass das
gas wieder fließt ist man in deutschland
vorbereitet ist die bundesregierung
vorbereitet und hat einen plan b
ich meine selbst robert habeck hat
gesagt wir müssen uns auf das schlimmste
vorbereiten es droht eine
gesellschaftliche zerreißprobe die und
die größte sorge ist eben dass diese
geile gasspeicher zur zuneige gehen wenn
der winter am aller kältesten wird das
heißt die bundesregierung versucht
aktuell verzweifelt weitere quellen für
gas zu erschließen markus söder hat
gestern erst gefordert die akw über den
31 12 hinaus weiterlaufen zu lassen um
ihm die gas und strom um weiterhin zu
entlasten das heißt das wird einfach die
nächste die große debatte in den
nächsten wochen und die lage ist
weiterhin und nach wie vor ernst besten
dank an die garage wie diese
einschätzungen vor ort am kanzleramt